it's andrea sant i'm a professor at the
university of rochester in the david h
smith center for vaccine biology and
immunology in rochester new york and my
primary interest is antigen presentation
and cd4 t cells and what i'd like to
talk with you about today is um
the potential for recruitment of memory
cd4 t cells that are established by
endemic human coronaviruses into the
responses to sar cov infection and
vaccination
so
sars as probably most of you know is the
causative agent and
coronavirus disease
and it has had a huge impact on public
health
tremendous amount of cases and deaths
worldwide and one of the really
interesting things to me is that there's
a
vast amount of variability in disease
presentation there's a wide range of
symptoms and disease paths
from severe to life-threatening to
asymptomatic
and there's known comorbidities which
are age and under the lying conditions
but there's a also a high degree of
unpredictability that does not track
with those parameters
and the vaccine responses are also
variable in peak and decay over time
so the premise of our work is that um
a contributing factor for the diverse uh
consequences of sar cov infection
vaccination is different um types of
memory in different human subjects
so the factors that might contribute to
the probability and consequences of
recall responses to sars cov infection
vaccination is exposure to
related endemic human coronaviruses and
i'll go over those in a couple slides
what those are
you need sufficient sequence identity
between the viral proteins to recruit
pre-existing immunity and tesar cov
infection
our hypothesis is that the impact of
recruitment of memory will depend on the
abundance and functional capacity of
cross-reactive t cells established by
human coronaviruses
and the challenge
which there's very little we can do
about right now
is that history of encounter with these
human coronaviruses
is really unknown
so the questions that are addressed in
our study is do people have detectable t
cells that react to endemic human
coronaviruses and i'll use this
abbreviation hcob to distinguish it from
sars and the other pathogenic
coronaviruses and what we know is that
humans are intermittently infected with
seasonal endemic coronaviruses
throughout life and there's very little
evidence of sterilizing immunity to
future infections and there's no
vaccines for human coronaviruses
therefore any t cell memory that has is
established will be established via
infection with these viruses and likely
multiple sequential infections over a
lifetime so this contrasts to the other
uh virus that we study a lot which is
influenza where memory is established by
both vaccination and infection and those
tend to recruit different types of
immunity
so the second question beyond can we
find these t cells is how does
expression of specific mediators of
human corona virus reactive cells vary
across the proteins in individuals
within the population
and is there a predictable phenotype of
human coronavirus reactive t cells in
humans and we use three mediators gamma
il-2 and granzyme and what's listed on
the slide is the different types of
effector functions they have
gamma is probably the most prototype
antiviral
cytokine but il-2 is really important
for health for cd4-t cell expansion and
memory and it can regulate the germinal
center reaction and granoxime b is an
interest of mind and it um
can participate in cytotoxic elimination
of antigen presenting cells or infected
cells
and so these are the coronaviruses the
human coronaviruses i mentioned they can
be broken
viruses on the left or beta
coronaviruses on the right and they were
only discovered
in recent decades
they have different receptors one uh
nl63 actually uses the same receptor
ace2 that's used by sars but the other
the betas use
glycosylated
glycoproteins on the surface
and another alpha coronavirus on the far
left is
human aminopeptidase n
and the target cells differ a bit with
these viruses and that could affect um
certainly disease pathology but also
the tropism of course of the virus and
maybe the effector function of the t
cells if they're infecting different
types of cells where an immune response
is taking place and these are listed
here
and what's also quite interesting here
is that
these viruses can become
um
systemic
which is quite different than what we
think of with other respiratory
pathogens that tend to stay in the
respiratory tract and you may have heard
about this with sars that uh virions can
be detected in many tissues
so this is a general scheme of the
genomic organization and really all i
want you to see from this is that
there's many parallels the overall
genetic organization is the same you
have these long open reading frames on
the left
that encode a series of proteins that
are proteolytically processed and encode
different proteins
and
orf1 a and 1b
and then there's structural proteins
which
include
spike nucleocapsid membrane and other
proteins so they're quite similar
huge and many of these genes control
many many different functions in uh
infected cells including antagonists and
antagonism of the innate response and
these are some of the things that we
really don't understand very much about
sars
so the epidemiology is interesting
infections typically occur first in
early childhood less than three years of
age and infections in these young kids
often occurs occur as co-infections with
other respiratory pathogens
there's very little little evidence be
beyond early childhood for age dependent
patterns and infection
when tracked by multiplex approaches to
detect respiratory pathogens so
typically that's done if somebody comes
into the hospital and has a respiratory
infection
they try to get a sample and then they
screen for many different pathogens so
that's how we know that um
the
frequency of infection doesn't change
very much and also when people do
intentional screening for human
coronaviruses
and repeated infections do occur despite
the lack of antigenic drift and escape
arguing for a lack of long-lived
protective sterilizing immunity and some
of these studies have been
done by other investigators who have
looked with cohorts
that they sample every six months or
year
and they come to the conclusion that
even within a single season people can
have a repeat infection with a given
coronavirus
and then so the timeline of uh isolation
of the
currently circulating coronavirus is
fairly recent and you can see here the
the time of these different um seasonal
ones on the top the endemic ones and
then the potentially the pathogenic ones
that have been identified in humans in
different places
and the year of isolation does not
indicate how long coronavirus has been
circulating
and the big challenge for this was
success and isolation and
characterization of these viruses
because there's a lack of suitable cell
types to culture the viruses and now
that we have more
sensitive
genetic tools
people can directly sequence the viruses
now this shows the emergence the
timeline of the emergence and you can
see that they've been around for a long
time nl 63 was many centuries ago
and
other ones are more recent so hku-1 was
in the 50s
and so you can see that they've been
and what they try to do is anticipate or
map where these viruses emerged from
what animals and you can see that many
came from bats and then they see it
diverging from current
bat or the animal
reservoir so this just shows again the
concept of open reading frames as well
as structural genes primarily our lab
has studied um but i'll show you some
data on sars with some of the open
reading frames and non-structural
proteins structural proteins we give
them that name because in viruses those
are the proteins that are seen in the
virion and those are uh for sars and the
coronaviruses
spike nuclear protein the membrane-like
approaching and there's a small envelope
protein and then there's some accessory
proteins as well as
open reading frames
so one of the big tools we use to test
for t cell reactivity is
peptide libraries
and some of you may not be familiar with
this
and i have a diagram of this i think on
the next slide where i'll show you that
it allows you to detect
um t-cells without really knowing what
they're going to be specific for
um it's just a comprehensive um set of
peptides that basically
represents the whole open reading frame
of
the translated pro
you can see here for sars what you'll
see in in our studies for the
coronavirus as well as sars is we divide
operationally the
sars or the spike protein
into s1 and s2 that gives us equal size
pools and these are also functionally
distinct regions of spike
and this just represents this type of
overlapping peptide library where you
can see they span um
typically for mhc class 2 which is uh
the
mhc molecule or hla molecule that
activates cd4 t cells those are
typically 14 to 18 mers and mhc class 2
can accommodate
rather large peptides because the
binding pocket of hla is
open at the end so the peptide can
extend out i'll show you a schematic on
the next slide of what those peptides
look like from hc class 1 they're
typically much smaller peptides so you
can use smaller peptide libraries and
those are
because the peptide binding pocket of
mhd is closed
and they can recall any specificity and
this is particularly good because um
you know you'll see and you may have
heard people trying to use predictive
algorithms which are based on trying to
anticipate what peptides
are presented by a given mhc but one of
the hallmark features of mhc or hla is
the incredible genetic and structural
diversity
so there's hundreds of these molecules
and people will express
anywhere from eight to ten different hla
class two molecules and a slightly
smaller number of hla class 1 molecules
and so what i just want to review for
you when we think about t cell
recognition is how do antigenic peptides
bind to mhc class 2 molecules and how
are they presented to t cell receptors
where is sequence related this relevant
for t-cell cross-reactivity between
these viruses
and this just shows you
um just examples of how
the gray is the mhc protein and this
just shows you how the colored segments
show you
how the peptide resides within the
peptide binding pocket mhc class 2 or
mhc class 1 where you can see a somewhat
larger pink occupancy of the peptide an
mhc class 2 and for the purpose of our
discussion you can see on the right
that there's
somewhat limited i mean it's amazing the
degree of discrimination that takes
place because you can see
for many of these
t cell receptors only a couple two to
three amino acids in the peptide are
recognized by the t cell receptor and
then facing down is the mhc context
contacts which are sometimes called the
anchors and those can be dominated by
three to four different ones and often
one dominant one
so this just shows you the type of
sequence identity that might be needed
and the degree of permissiveness if the
if the amino acid variation is quite
um
similar
to the original one you might get cross
reactivity so it's not any substitution
and certainly non-conservative changes
you would guess would be less permissive
so here's just all you need to see from
here is sort of the concept of sequence
identity and here yellow is um different
among the four coronaviruses and stars
and black is identical
and all i really want you to see from
this is that if you look at the spike on
the right you can see the bottom is s2
and that just has more regions of
sequence identity with the human corona
virus and sars so the options for that
and nuclear capsule also has some of
those and then i'll show you a little
bit uh later
that within a given family so if i
looked just at the beta corona viruses
which sars is there might be more
sequence identity with sars but you can
see they they really are quite different
from each other but there are segments
that could theoretically allow
memory established by these human
coronaviruses to be
recalled and um
this is an example of uh the subjects
that we use in our studies
and the it's a basic assay set up and
you can see on the right that we give
each subject a different symbol
you know squares or circles and these
are all different colors and they differ
in age and sex and those are the things
that we recover
and record in our studies
and
this allows us to track the same subject
from
reaction to reaction so if somebody
reacts prominently with one coronavirus
does it also react really robustly and i
think these are more valuable they're
kind of
challenging to make for the people that
make these graphs but i think it does
make it easier to to really understand
these responses
our pbmcs are from healthy subjects and
this is a really important point
in looking at our data all the data i'm
going to show you were collected before
to the 2019
so there's going to be no people that
were infected with sars and our subjects
there's no history history of
respiratory infection for six weeks
prior
we deplete and eliminate cd8 and cd56
and k cells so that the only cytokines
we detect are from the cd4 t cells and
there's also antigen presenting cells in
the culture and ele spot assays are used
to estimate the number of cells
secreting the mediators in response to
distinct peptides and we plate these t
cells at a sufficiently limited dilution
such that each spot represents an
individual t cell that's responding to
those peptides one of those peptides or
potentially more and so our data is
represented as the frequency of cytokine
producing cells per million
cd4 essentially c4 enriched populations
and this again just illustrates the
point that we're going to be studying
the structural genes primarily and we
incorporate these are the the
mediators we track and we have several
um controls that we typically track one
is flu b because it's something that we
find in most human subjects memory to
flu b is probably the most pronounced
and we look at the structural genes
indicated here
and in many of our studies we use a
negative pool of peptides because
sometimes peptides are suppressive
in culture maybe because of the organic
solvents that are used
so the first thing i'll show you is in
these subjects collected prior to 2019
when we test with
s1 proteins from these
endemic coronaviruses you can see that
virtually everybody in our panel and all
these are different people as indicated
by the symbol
have detectable reactivity
and it's what this indicates is
learning from the epidemiology is that
everybody's been exposed we can't infer
from here like that the high person you
can see like nl 63 the blue square
person in the far right that they were
most recently
infected because people the longevity of
people's antibody responses is really
quite variable but that says that there
was contact with them and you can see
what the s1 protein that we use that's
the most distinctive on the bottom
schematic there
and here's the t cell reactivity now if
we look at the total and the antigens
are at the bottom these are the seasonal
coronaviruses
the
betas are on the left and the alters on
the right and you can see here that
there's a tremendous range in reactivity
and this was very surprising to us
because we assumed that most people have
been exposed you know multiple times so
we really didn't know what we would find
when we did these assays and you can see
gamma il-2 and granzyme and so we can
detect all these mediators
and when we looked at individual
subjects even though you can't see it
from here virtually everybody had cd for
reactivity when you when using um these
mediators to these cd4 t cell reactivity
to these um
coronavirus epitopes so this is putting
the whole peptide pool into our early
spot assays you can just see the
tremendous range in reactivity so that's
the kind of thing we were
sort of wondering about is it variable
and is the phenotype variable and one of
the ways and i'll point this out later
but you can see for example
hku1 the second one in there if you look
at is the phenotype the same you could
look at the gamma the top for hku one
the second one in
has sort of modest reactivity by gamma
but it tends to recruit a lot of
grandson production and so that tells us
that the phenotype of the cells that
could be cross-reactively recruited into
the response to sars vaccines or
infection
could be quite distinct in different
subjects
and now we break it down into s1 and s2
and you can see that again the
tremendous range and one of the things
that we noticed here
was that when we looked at the alpha
coronaviruses there was enrichment and
reactivity to s2 over s1 and this was
more pronounced in the alpha
coronaviruses boxed in blue compared to
the beta corona viruses in in sort of
orange
and we were surprised at this
peptide pools are about the same size
and we didn't know why they were
enriched
um so this again how this is where again
we come back to our
idea of looking at sequence identity and
what we saw from this where we're
comparing the beta's
um identity with each other and again
black is the same and yellow means
they're different what you can see is
that the betas have are distinct really
from both the s1 and the s2
whereas the alphas have much more
sequence identity in the s2 domain
and this may be
this may allow
cross priming so if a person got
infected sequentially with nl 63
and um
229e
sequentially
over a season over the next season those
two infections could cross boost each
other and that would enrich the boosting
you would think would enrich for
reactivity you'd expand those t cells
and they could persist but also if the
functionality of the cells is different
those cross-reactive
infections could change the phenotype of
the cells within the lineage
so
is the uh functional potential the same
among the cells i've already sort of
hinted that it isn't
and this is one way that we've looked at
this and i mentioned to that when we
looked at the intact stars and what you
can see here
and i've just boxed the
beta corona viruses and what you can see
is if you look at gamma on the top that
they're you know within the era of the
experiment they're pretty similar but
then if you look at grandson you could
see that that some ocs oc 43 s1 has
almost
no grand zone is produced in response to
those epitopes whereas there's a lot of
these cytotoxic cells with cytotoxic
potential and hku1 and particularly with
s2 and this is really intriguing to us
because when we think about what
cytolytic t cells can do
it will depend on where they go if they
go into the lung those cells could
potentially eliminate virus infected
cells and that would be good if they go
into the lymph node those cytotoxic
cells could potentially go in and
actually eliminate energy presenting
cells or b cells and that would be bad
for the immune response so we're
intrigued by this as well as just the
the overall difference in the phenotype
among different subjects
and this is another way we represent it
we
we represented as ratios within each
person so we look at in a given person
what was the ratio of gamma to il-2
granzyme to il-2 or grandson to gamma
and really all i want you to see from
here is that it's different among
different subjects
the ratio so it basically means the
population of cells that are reactive to
these viruses will be different
and the way the reason we do it is
ratios is because this allows us whether
the ratio is two to one or 20 to one
doesn't really matter it's just
you are you here if you do it within a
subject you can sort of normalize for
people that were either
high responders or low responders and
you can see generally what are the
tendencies but if you look at the y-axis
and you can see here that relative to um
gamma on the far right there's generally
fewer grands on producing cells
in most people but not all people
because equal numbers would give you a
ratio of one and many are below that but
some are above that
and why might these functionality be
different it could be the number of
infections over a lifetime
or cross boosting as we discussed it
could be co-infections with other
respiratory pathogens and because
remember i mentioned that the kids can
get co-infections and it's possible that
if a
child had a co-infection with particular
bacteria or virus that micro environment
in the lung could imprint the
functionality of cd4 t cells and that
could persist by recall during the
course of the lifetime and then across
viruses tropism different receptors
which could affect of course the cells
that are
presenting antigen to the t cells as
well as the micro environment of the t
cells where they're being primed
and now we want to look at is there
evidence now that we know that there's
memory to sars and
entering sars peptide pools into the
assay and you can see yes among these
subjects there's many people who have
reactivity to sars proteins if you use
gamma you can see nucleic acid is
particularly prominent s2
is also prominent that's on the the left
the the gamma
and less with
the
membrane and
envelope protein and so this says that
there are even in people that don't have
any sars infections you can see that
they would have potential the potential
ability to respond to these epitopes
um
interestingly the um the spike seems to
have no production of granzyme whereas
nucleocapsid does and we don't know the
reason for that it's part
possible that nucleocapsid tends to
carry some viral rna along with it when
it's priming t cells and maybe that's
why it has more granulon but we really
don't understand this and one of the big
difficulties in dissecting the
mechanisms responsible for this
variability in phenotype is the lack of
good animal models um for the diversity
of human coronaviruses the the receptors
are not the same in human and mice or
ferrets and also it's very hard to model
uh repeated infections over time because
most of the animal models the animals
only live for a couple years so you
can't really mimic a 50 year old person
who's had 15 infections
and then when we do a larger fraction of
um
uh we now look at the whole proteome and
this is just preliminary data you can
see that there's reactivity in these
pre-2019
um
samples and they tend to be
enriched for some over others and this
is just gans granzyme or sorry gamma
that we've done so far
and we sort of operationally for the
this large graph
presented as large proteins or
small nsps
and you can see and this is again
something i don't understand we don't
understand yet you can see there's
occasional people like the yellow circle
person or blue circle person that has
high reactivity to all of these and none
of these people have had
sars as far as we know unless there was
some
circulating in 2016 which we don't know
about but there's some people that just
have high levels of these and other
people that have very low cross
reactivity and we don't think this is
due to general selectivity of mhc
because as i mentioned earlier people
have a lot of mhc proteins and there's a
lot of
peptides that they could have responded
to
so this is really fascinating and it
could reflect
could be reflected in the outcome of
infection the different inherent
reactivities that people have with sars
and this is another way we look at the
data we call this immunogenicity because
this normalizes for the size of the
protein so some of these
proteins in the previous representation
were sort of penalized because they're
tiny so they don't have a lot of
epitopes and here we've just normalized
for the size of the protein and you can
see here
that
there is
some proteins that seem to be more
immunogenic
and you can just see this by the height
of the average or the really high
responders in this
graph and we use the word cross
reactivity to explain
um why we think there's cross reactivity
the sars and to test whether or not this
was valid we just compared reactivity
the same scheme where black is conserved
we sort of made selected peptide pools
that were highly conserved versus not in
the nuclear capsid which offers both
types of epitopes
and you can see here with this selection
that in fact the ones that we judge to
be conserved and none of them are
absolutely conserved but the ones that
are conserved between
coronaviruses the endemic ones because
these are sars nucleocapsid peptides
those tend to the
conserved ones tend to recruit more so
we think um our conclusion is that the
reactivity we're detecting does as well
as the sequence identity does correlate
with
sequence identity in the peptides
that
could recruit
the same set of t cells
and this is
basically the last data slide it just
shows you something unexpected that we
found which is that
in looking at
coronaviruses you can see all of them
here
there is um
an age dependent decline in the
circulating levels
of t cells specific for this
these either s1 on the top or s2 on the
on the bottom
and this was very surprising because
we've been studying influenza for a long
time and you can see on the far right
here hab reactivity and there's really
no um
we really don't see if you look for very
very elderly people a 90 year old you
know you might see um because
immunosenescence takes place and so one
of the things we don't know about is
although people are there's no evidence
for
age-dependent declines infection over
time what could be going on here is that
maybe in older people the t-cells don't
boost so much or maybe they decay more
leading to an overall less robust
circulating level but again this could
affect their susceptibility to sars
because they would have fewer
cross-reactive cells
and so our conclusions are do people
have t cells reacted to endemic
coronaviruses yes and it's enriched in
most cases for um
s2 and s1
how does expression of different cytok
cells and it's there's tremendous
population level uh variability
and uh there's patterns of abundance
related to age as well as functional
potential that's linked to a large
extent but not exclusively to the
protein specificity of the t cells
and they might have a given person might
have many t cells specific for
uh s2 when measured by gamma but but
little if you measure il2
and the consequences and reasons for
this are not known
and there are people that have obvious
cd4 t cell memory that could be
recruited to sars
and our future directions are to
understand the origin and mechanisms
that lead to
uh the differences in functional
potential of cd4 t cells we're looking
to extend the age groups and separately
query beta and alpha coronaviruses and
also memory to other respiratory
pathogen and we want to look at um
those the actual recruitment of these
cross-reactive cells in uh sarah's cov
vaccinated infected subjects and we've
collected some samples now that we can
look at
and then the last thing i want to thank
the people in my lab who've done this
primarily the ones that are in bold and
circled on this photo
from left to right or
left to right on the photo is maria
glover chantelle white and katie skelly
and um we've collaborated on a lot of
these studies with paul thomas and
jeremy crawford and katie allen at st
jude and these are our funding sources
thanks very much for your attention i
hope you've learned something that you
didn't know about cd4t cell memory to
human endemic coronaviruses and stars
thank you